hosting the border with venezuela before
Colombian transients venezuelensis
like this title and the duplex penthouse district
to the future of light country came to me
a week ago on tuesday
that to study and a whole problem
that to eat day to day a problem
For you, keeping your city is a
problem.
Islam is the one from the Spain section. I have a
cousin in Spain. They have left because of the
need to look for new horizons.
We are trying to get the
documents from my children to see if they
have another chance, better than him.
here in venezuela
venezuela
today is at home because of jail I think it is
a measure that was achieved with such force
at the international level at the national level
we ask a lot we denounce the
inhuman treatment a lot and it was possible for the
people to be with their family in my house
but they are in prison
in prison
hearst cannot express himself then a
very delicate situation because if he is in
a house he is no longer in a
military prison but he is absolutely  nte limited
and remains isolated
we have
in any more or less healthy democracy
I who right now pay attention to the president of
the assembly the normal thing would be to
have some kind of relationship with the
other powers that are venezuela there
is no
stiglitz in venezuela there is no freedom of
expression
the government  has co-opted and at the same
time oppressed the
media threatens
journalists there are many people in prison
simply for having posted a twitter
that they are present in the desert
and then the world lost weight because
everything no longer has the same food it
had before and  they consider themselves to be able to do
it 400 or 500 in 500 million it is an
antibiotic and it has dawned and they confer the
sacred prize of freedom and they
defeated the opposition and democratic
I think it is more recognition than the
parliament I think it is a recognition of
the Venezuelan people  Venezuelan people have spent
years fighting in all
spaces for their freedom